this video is sponsored by Sunny dianis
art this is your reminder that the BBC
has yet to address the consistent
transphobic leanings in its news
coverage and while the team behind
Doctor Who is not connected to this in
any way since this is a BBC owned
property I'm going to keep pointing it
out until the problem gets resolved
links in a pin comment below if you
don't know what I'm talking about I'll
stop saying it when it stops being a
[Music]
problem yes I know it would have been
more appropriate for me to use the blue
light which is the default on this model
but I only just for how change the
colors let me have my
[Music]
[Applause]
fun than there you happy now before we
get into it I want to tell you about
this episode sponsor Sunny dianis is an
artist with a YouTube channel a Twitter
account and a portfolio that you can
peruse see the art that he has put
together and commission him for work he
has a wonderful Unique Style is easy to
work with and is someone I'm proud to
have as a sponsor on this video I highly
encourage you to peruse his social
medias see what he does get sense of his
work and if you're feeling like you want
something a little bit special for a
family member a friend or for yourself
consider commissioning some of his Art
thank you to Sunny for sponsoring this
video and now off we go into the wild
blue
yonder wild blue yonder second of the
Doctor Who specials and the second to
feature David Tennant as the 14th doctor
Katherine Tate returning as Donna Noble
and Russell T Davis at the Helm of the
show oh
boy
okay let me say this up
front this is the kind of thing that
gets me genuinely excited for more
Doctor Who the previous episode which I
did like I did like the starbeast for
the most part I had nitpicks but I have
nitpicks about everything including
about this we'll get there but um
I swimming in Nostalgia is the best way
I could describe the appeal of the
previous one of the star Beast
this this gets me excited for the things
doctor who might do different and this
feels like a really good second entry
because that first one yeah swimming in
Nostalgia brought back lots of good
feelings but also made me nervous that
it was largely just going to feel like
Russell T Davis was trying to do what he
did you know 10 to 15 years ago and I'm
like I don't like I want something that
feels a little Bolder than that and so I
get this I'm like
okay there that's what I'm talking about
I like this a lot there's great
atmosphere phenomenal performances a
terrific sense of isolation I'm going to
end up comparing this to the episode
midnight from series 4 a fair bit and I
think that's a fair thing to do given
that both are written by Russell T Davis
um but uh overall the impressions are
very very positive I am going to have
nitpicks I will bring up some stuff but
let's get the the most glaring problem
out of the way I hate this cold open I
really hate it I hate the jokey tone
it's doing the Oh look The drct Donna
run into a famous person thing that like
I wish Doctor Who would stop doing
granted I appreciate that it wasn't the
bulk of the episode it was done as a
joke but even as a joke just stop I
don't I don't want any more of this and
it has nothing to do with anything else
I'd actually say it interrupts the sense
of danger like okay you got on top of
the fire in the Tardis long enough to
crack jokes about Isaac Newton and set
up the idea that from now on the show is
going to call it mavity instead of
gravity
mavity that'll probably get amended next
episode because we'll I don't know
correct timelines or something but
regardless like why is this here it
exists for no reason other than to have
a cold open you don't always need a cold
open drop the cold open just start with
the credits that would have been fine
there's literally one thing I like about
this and that is Donna pointing out do
you have do you just have this thing set
to famous people which normally that
kind of lampshade hanging might annoy me
because I'm like yeah yeah I I know I
don't like that and I know the show
knows it's not great because they just
made a joke out of it except putting it
in in the mouth of a character like
Donna and having Katherine Tate deliver
it yeah I actually I actually did laugh
that at that and that was fine I also
like okay I'm going to point this out
just because I don't care but it's going
to annoy me regardless because it
doesn't matter if I care Isaac Newton
they cast somebody non-white fine I
super don't care however I know that
that nonsense is going to be blaring at
me in the online discourse of this
freaking thing and no I'm not going to
talk about it because I don't care I
don't so if you have strong feelings
about this go ahead and have them
somewhere else
please okay now I can actually talk
about the episode proper as I said I
like this pretty much right off the bat
I love just the sense of scale I love
when they're just out in that Corridor
and just how far everything stretched I
love just this dark figure far in the
distance can't tell what it is can't
even tell if it's moving I mean
eventually we get to it later it turns
out it wasn't but like it was like is it
just walk at a calm pace and that's why
cuz there just so much distance across
you don't know Wonderful sense of
isolation and then you get up to the
cockpit still nothing well there's space
but if that's space where are the stars
what are what are the words we're
hearing why is the ship
reconfiguring and the sense of isolation
of loneliness and like it hammers that
really well Donna
feels the weight and the idea that they
don't know how they're going to get back
oh let's back up the Tardis running away
in of itself fine the fact that the
doctor stuck the Sonic Screwdriver in it
no Tardis no
Sonic Oh see now like I am somebody who
by and large defends the use of the
Sonic most of the time there are some
people like it solves too many problems
yet generally as a rule it solves
problems that would be uninteresting to
take the time to fix that's why it's
used on doors and as scanning so much
because most of the time it would not be
interesting to watch the doctor pick a
door lock nor would it be particularly
interesting to watch the doctor figure
out you know what this is we just need
the information to keep the thing to
keep the story moving just have it get
it off get it off the Sonic I'm fine
with that by and large
but this shows that sometimes yeah strip
him of his tools take it away and I
don't think this is an argument for
getting rid of the Sonic as a general
thing but it does show that like
sometimes yeah having the Sonic would
have hurt this story cool so he doesn't
have it not this
time love that love that but as I said
the sense of size scale the enormity of
space
is conveyed really well the idea that
they're not in some pocket Dimension
they're not separate from the universe
they're at the edge of the universe
meaning they are so far away from where
everything is that no light has yet
reached this point that's existentially
terrifying and we've seen companions
like have these moments of what if I
can't get home again Donna sell like you
really feel like she thinks she's not
going to get back and she sells just the
the weight of that hitting her she sells
that really well and then the way the
not
things are
introduced in a way that initially just
made me go wait are we doing nonlinear
storytelling are we just messing with
time a little bit here having the doctor
show up and start talking talking to
Donna having Donna show up in the room
and start talking to the
doctor and realizing and you know my as
I said my first instinct was like time
dilation or just like funky editing no
no no no no there's there's something
else going on
here and just feeling that sink in but
also not just using it as a moment to be
a bit creepy which it is effectively so
but also just using it as a moment to
characterize both the doctor and Donna
and contrast them because both of them
do the same thing but it illustrates how
these things are different for them
because for Donna she thinks what's my
family going to do if I never go back
she crafts this story about how Rose
will come back every year Shawn will
come back every
day and just lays that out meanwhile the
doctor says well what'll happen to the
TARDIS it'll just land somewhere and
just stay there forever that's what he
has left I mean like he has Donna but in
terms of like the permanence of a sense
of family what he has is the TARDIS so
they do the same thing her for her
family him just for the Tardis I love
that contrast and I love that the
introdu the introdution
introduction of these not things is done
this smoothly this
creepily and in a way that is not just
hey creepy thing going on let's
characterize and give you good moments
with the doctor and with
Donna so I'm going to pause another
minute here at this point I am giving up
on the idea that the 14th doctor is
going to be very distinguishable from
the 10th it's very clear they're not
doing that and yes I have now at this
point actually seen some bits from an
interview or something of that nature
where they both um David Tenant and
Russell T Davies kind of acknowledge
that will people notice any differences
there wouldn't be any point in me coming
back to then play it completely
differently I don't think that' be a big
disappoint familiarity yeah while I will
always I think consider it a missed
opportunity that they didn't do
something different like have a lot of
aspects of the 10th doctor but have it
be more
distinguishable I I'm always going to
feel that's a missed
opportunity that being said
here's something I really appreciate
about these
specials if you're not going to alter
the
characterization then the least you
could do is present stories in which
they are actually going to benefit from
leaning on the established
characterization and the established
Dynamics between him and Donna and the
last episode already did it because it
allows them to click back into place
pretty much immediately this one
hinges heavily on that dynamic as they
interact with each other and with the
not things and have to figure out who is
who and what is what yeah actually this
is a story that couldn't necessarily be
told at all if you were going to have
the 14th doctor be more distinctly
different from the 10th I mean you could
but I think this is a story that
functions better having him just slip
back into that old Persona a bit more
I'm not going to stop thinking of it as
a missed opportunity but I do at least
appreciate that if this is what we're
doing that the stories being told this
one
especially benefit from the fact that
he's not being done differently good
that means that you didn't have him just
act like the 10th doctor strictly out of
nostalgia or creative
laziness you did it well maybe maybe you
did it just because you're like that's
how we're going to do it but then either
you either had stories that you realized
he'd benefit best by acting like the
10th doctor or you took the fact that
he's basically just the 10th doctor
again and crafted stories that do the
most with that either way whatever order
it happened in good good cuz like I can
accept sometimes creative decisions
being made that aren't what I would
prefer
if something comes out of it if
something comes out of it
that is a good story a good character
development good
something that either couldn't be done
if you didn't make that that creative
choice I'd prefer you didn't or it works
better with that car with that creative
choice in place I'm going to be more
accepting even if my personal preference
would still be that you hadn't made that
specific creative choice because at the
very least it wasn't for no reason you
benefited from it you built something
off that choice good
so that that was good to see now the
point at which I kind of paused to talk
about that was before I was going to
have to start talking
about the special effects okay
so here's the thing I think that the
points at which the effects take over
with the not things are some of the
weakest points both visually and in
terms of the story
because when it when they're just
there just looking mostly if not
entirely like the doctor and
Donna then there's this sense of
unease the sense of you don't know what
they're going to do but then a jaw
unhinges or the arms are too long or
they grow to this massive freaking size
you're like oh okay well that that's
what we're doing the tension out of I
don't know what you're going to do is
gone in addition to the fact that the
CGI and the effects aren't great the
thing is is I'm not sure that these
moments would work for me at least any
better if the effects were seamless I
like I think the only one that really
worked for me well no there were two the
very first stuff with the arms being too
long that kind of worked and when Donna
had two knees in her leg that worked for
me oh three I suppose the do the copy of
the doctor dropping on all fours to run
faster that was good so like out of all
the stuff that they do you know the jaw
drop the getting real big the melting
into a puddle the backward Bend and he's
literally talking out of his own rear
end like even if the CGI was seamless I
think I'd have the same feelings about
most of these moments I think they're
they're too much they're they're they're
showing too much and I think less would
have been more and this is where I'm
going to start comparing it to midnight
so midnight was a series 4 episode that
was just the doctor Donna was in the
episode technically in the beginning at
the end but she wasn't present it was
just the doctor on this tour bus with
some other people dealing with this
thing where no one knew what it was
doing or why and I've always just
referred to it as the midnight entity
and we learn almost nothing about that
thing we see how it operates we don't
know what it's trying to accomplish we
don't know where it came from we don't
know what its goals are we just know how
it's operating and it's a
masterpiece shamble bubble dible doble
this I think sort of demonstrates why
giving us more information about
something like the the midnight entity
would not make the story any better cuz
I think honestly we learn a little more
about these things and we see a little
too much about the specifics of what
they're capable of at least in terms of
like the morphing and whatnot that it
actually demystifies them slightly not
completely like they're still in that
ballpark but I I can't help but make
that comparison and I kind of wish we
saw a little less of their capabilities
and knew a little less about them than
we do that is admittedly a bit of a
nitpick if midnight as an episode did
not exist I probably would be um less
critical of this particular aspect but
that episode does exist and it's written
by the same person so I think the
comparison is fair and I do want to
emphas I think the performances from
both David Tennant and Katherine Tate in
this are great as both half like I love
that this is this is a two-hander for
all intens and purposes there's only two
actors four characters in this and it's
really well done and I love that they
find very organic ways like due to the
fact that the ship keeps shifting to
split the doctor and Donna up so they
have to go through the routine again
like ah crap I don't know if you're you
and I really loved it the first first
time when they got um like deliberately
not well not deliberately but after they
realized there are copies of each other
and they got split up first time they
have to try and figure out I love the
completely different tones in the scenes
between Donna and the copy of the doctor
and the doctor and the copy of Donna and
yes I will get to some of the specifics
of what was said there give me a second
let me appreciate the tone first I love
that for the one with Donna the real
Donna it's snappier it's funnier it's
Wittier it's more fast-paced well then
it's me
no and then with the doctor the real
Doctor it's more Melancholy it's more
somber your same is to break me down and
they're both doing the same thing
they're both trying to sus out the other
person that they're in the room
with but the tones are almost night and
day and that should
conflict but it
doesn't because that that's kind of The
Duality of not only these characters but
of these characters together they are
that fast-paced they do bounce off of
each other that quick they are that
rapid fire they are that funny but
they're also that serious they're also
that emotional they're also that hit you
right in the heart and to set up
something like this to explore and give
us tastes of both sides of these
characters and their Dynamic at the same
time in parallel scenes cutting between
them
love it and yes this does give us
confirmation and this is basically about
what I expected CU Russell D Davis had
mentioned before that he in has no
intention of reconning the Timeless
child uh and there was going to be a
small acknowledgement of it and that is
here with the uh side of the scene
that's between the actual do doctor and
the copy of Donna with the
acknowledgement that the doctor is not
from galif Fray and he doesn't know
where he comes from you don't know where
you're
from and for me this is actually the
more important part that half the
universe was destroyed and it wasn't
restored the FL it destroyed half the
universe because of
me thank you if you're new around here
for any reason one of my
many many problems with flux is that it
really did seem like a huge swath of the
universe was destroyed in that story and
it wasn't restored that in and of itself
wasn't the problem but nobody ever
acknowledged it that they lost half the
universe they just jaunt off on their
next adventure the doctor didn't
acknowledge it Yas didn't Dan didn't
nobody said anything we get an
acknowledgement and it's tearing him up
that half the universe is gone and he
didn't save it good we stand here now on
the on the edge of creation a creation
which I devastated it should but also I
love that this Donna even though she's a
copy she says what Donna would have said
which is that it's not your fault it
wasn't your fault I know
chel this is the dramatic and
storytelling meat you could have pulled
off of the bones of the idea of the flux
and of the consequences of it and you
just didn't that was ultimately my
biggest frustration with chipil some of
it was that I didn't like his ideas but
a lot of it was that he didn't even do
much with the ideas he put out with one
scene a couple of lines one interaction
between characters Russell T Davis got
more out of the fact that a huge swath
of the universe is gone than chimel even
attempted to
do that's that's
impressive as for the effectively
acknowledging and I'm not going to say
canonizing it was already Canon but the
re affirmation that yes the Timeless
child is a thing and the doctor doesn't
know where he comes from this is about
what I expected like an acknowledgement
that that's the case and then moving on
that's about what I would want from
somebody like Russell T Davis I think
and I've said this repeatedly before I
think the Timeless child should be
handled the exact same way that the show
has handled the fact that it was
revealed the doctor is half human in the
TV movie from 1996 leave it alone and
don't talk about it did they talk about
it here yeah we did get some decent
moments out of it which I just praised a
little bit well more than a little bit
it went off on chibo a little bit too
sorry force a habit but you know I don't
think it's a massive damage to be like
yeah the doctor doesn't know where he
comes from and as far as whatever impact
the Timeless child thing is ever going
to have on the doctor that's about the
extent that I would want it to be I'm
okay with it Weighing on the doctor that
he doesn't know where he originates from
I don't ever want to to find out I have
no interest I've said before well
honestly even within this thing I've
said demystifying things too much takes
away some of their power that is true of
these monsters which it doesn't happen
too much but it happens a little and
that is very true of the doctor the more
we know about the specifics of his life
outside of the adventures we've seen him
in not only do I not care I actually
find that stuff bafflingly and
aggressively uninteresting I don't care
where he came from but you can still get
some dramatic weight out of the fact
that it eats at him that he doesn't know
okay like I don't want him to know but
if you want to milk a little a little
drum out of that okay I'm okay with that
I don't want the Timeless child explored
as a concept but if you want to actually
do something with its impact on the
doctor as a character much like this
scene does something with the impact of
half the universe being gone okay if you
want to do that I can I can live with
that that's fine and so coming back to
it every scene where it's well honestly
basically every scene from when the
copies first show up it's so good it's
so good watching them one-on-one with
each other and like Donna expressing
well copy Donna expressing that she
knows and later on we find out real
Donna doesn't and I I buy that
explanation given as to why the copy
could actually remember and this Donna
can't it's too much it's like looking
into a furnace but I suppose she had a
great big outspace brain she could make
sense of it yeah I'm cool with that I I
I buy that explanation that this thing
was some kind of weird Alien Cosmic
entity that while it was copying Donna
it had its own brain that could fit that
info Donna can't so like I'm I'm cool
with that but like just getting those
moments and and seeing the for of them
and and the the back and forth about the
fact that Donna can believe two things
at once once and like these little
things that these that these not things
haven't gotten a hold of yet the fact
that the doctor one forgot that the tie
needs to continue to exist oh I
see I'm something is going to keep
existing he didn't get object permanence
yet cuz he hasn't had enough experience
of life to to get all the rules whether
it's that or like the arms are a little
too long or whatever it might be just
the little things like they're not quite
getting yet just gives it that sense of
unease again watching them get better
and get smarter and get quicker about it
we're as clever as you now and the scene
again you know where it's all four of
them and the dark points out Don I can
believe two things at once cuz these
these things whatever they are they
don't get ambivalence yet they don't get
the complexities of having to
conflicting thoughts in you at the same
time cuz that's incredibly human and
they don't know that yet they don't get
that not because they're incapable but
because they haven't had cause to learn
that that's a thing yet the salt was
kind of cute I dug that I like the way
that the donop gets around it which is
to go wait a minute and just blow the
salt away okay it's not a line
anymore that that felt really good it
was a legitimately solid joke where
they're like against the wall and the
countdown starts the wall spins and n's
like well that was lucky but then it
spins 360° and they're right back in the
room that was good that was like a good
little joke moment I really
love with the glass wall between them
these entities on one side doctor and
Donna on the other the doctor and Donna
like trying to go Zen trying to calm
down all right we're not thinking and
then these things basically go the
doctor into thinking because they bring
up all the questions that he doesn't
have answers to yet and there's
questions that need answers and he
cannot stop
himself let me let me let
me these scenes they're great and
they're tense and they get the doctor
they get Donna it's not just putting
them on display it is examining them it
is pulling them apart for you and going
here's some of the inner workings and
that's a dangerous thing to do with
characters cuz as a as a rule often when
you start to Deon Ru things and start to
show the inner workings too much it can
again be that demystification or like
they can stop working because you're
like oh that's how everything operates
okay well now I just know but like to
give us the insight into like the things
they can't help the fact that Donna even
though she knows she's brilliant
sometimes also can't help with things
she's stupid the fact that the doctor
even though he knows it's literally
going to empower the things trying to
kill him can't stop himself from trying
to figure things out that's nice cuz
again that's a little bit of a call back
to midnight in that in that episode the
doctor tried to talk his way out of a
situation but talking made it worse but
he couldn't stop himself here
thinking thinking at a rapid speed brain
firing in a million miles an hour trying
to sort everything out it makes it worse
but he can't help
it love it and I like the answers as
well I like the idea that going
slow calm it's harder for them to
read like why I don't care I buy it I
buy it so with that rule
established the robot starts to make
sense the countdown well it gets
revealed that it is a countdown but that
starts to make sense I like the emphasis
and the honoring of the captain the dead
Captain because ultimately the doctor
and Don uh well they made the situation
worse by showing up the captain's plan
was always going to work whether they
showed up or not so I like that one of
the last things we see when the whole
thing blows up is the captain's body
because yeah if it wasn't for the
captain this all would have ended
horribly so again it just feels like a
nice little acknowledgement of something
that often would have been a throwaway
like oh there's a dead body like no
let's get some acknowledgement like
we're never going to fully see this
character fully characterize them but we
can have a moment or two of appreciation
and I feel like this does that very well
it it makes me care about a character we
literally never see other than a
floating corpse but I do care a little
bit and I feel a sense of Triumph for
this dead alien Captain when the ship
blows up and the very
slow the way they say that that's so
good and I love you know trying to
outwit them but like as the not thing
doctor points out like we're as clever
as you now can you really stop us just
the back and the forth and the tension
it's so good and somehow two specials in
a row Davis
you part of me knows Donna's gonna
survive but last episode I got genuinely
nervous when the metac crisis filled her
up again she became the do Donna and
they had the moment with the doctor
holding her and I legitimately choked up
here I didn't choke up but I was
terrified I felt my stomach drop when
the Tardis shows up first of all I love
the explanation that because the Tardis
is a time machine and it experiences
time a little bit differently it knows
that the not thing doctor won't succeed
and the thing will blow up so it can
come back a little bit early but a time
machine would
[Music]
know I like that I dig it um make sense
to me so but when when the doctor takes
the wrong one which first of all so few
shows would have the Goon to do that
like generally the point of a scene like
that is to show the connection show the
special thing that only they have that
this thing couldn't
replicate in the moment it fooled
him my stomach dropped when I realized
that was still Donna left
behind on me I'm me and her watching
this explosion thinking she's going to
die I was terrified for her I should
have known like I'm sure somewhere in
the back of my head I did know she's
gonna be okay but dang it Davies two
episodes in a row you got me on the edge
of my seat thinking Donna was going to
die or at least emotionally being
invested as if she was going to even if
part of me knew she she wouldn't you got
me again you
a
[Music]
you
so this is this is just great I love
this I have my nitpicks cold open sucks
it flatly sucks I don't like it at all
and I think that the they did too many
of the special effects I think if they
had dialed that back done fewer of them
had them be subtler I think that would
have benefited it more even more so than
it would have just if they just flat out
looked better
but the sense of isolation the sense of
tension the dynamic between these
characters every time there were
multiple versions of them in the room it
was always gold this is really good and
of course we end we get to see wolf hey
there folks it's me during the editing
phase I went on for a little bit about
not being sure whether or not wolf would
be seen in the next episode it's since
been confirmed by Russell T Davies that
he will not be so I'm going to jump
ahead a bit I know I'll still be talking
in the video as if I don't know but just
be aware that's been confirmed i' I've
seen some things that suggest that this
scene was all they got shot with Bernard
cribbons before he passed away and if
that's true and the next episode opens
with a small time Jump and Donna like
thanking the doctor for dropping wil off
somewhere safe before they try and solve
this or whatever you know some line to
cover that if this is all we get God it
choked me up
immediately the sense
of joy and relief from him at seeing the
doctor and seeing
Donna oh damn
it yep yep yep so if this is
it if they either didn't get stuff shot
with him for the next one or they didn't
get enough shot where it's it's usable
if this is it one scene made it count I
don't have
predictions for the next episode I don't
really do them by and large um I am like
I kind of made a small one which is that
I think timelines are some like in some
way are going to be rectified amended or
uh in some way healed to cover things
for like I don't expect the show to say
mavity for the entirety of the rest of
however long it runs so I expect like
small things like that will over the
course of that story be reversed or
amended or whatever and it's now
occurred to me that if history being
changed so that gravity is called mavity
and that gets addressed and somehow
becomes a plot point that it shows the
toy makers's influence in the next
episode that some people will argue see
there was a reason for the cold open I
will still argue it didn't belong where
it was I would still say find a way to
put it in the previous episode have it
be the cold open to the next one or have
this be between when the doctor and
Donna escape and before they get back to
that alley in London I probably still
wouldn't like it regardless but I
probably dislike it less if it wasn't
the cold open just move it but I don't
really do
predictions my brain doesn't work that
way I'm I'm really bad for speculation I
can't think oh maybe it's this maybe
it's this because part of my brain goes
quit speculating and just watch it in a
week find out what it is then see what
you think the last one was a
nostalgic warm bath this is a tense
Thrill Ride that knows when to slow down
knows when to go quieter knows when to
be tense knows when to be Melancholy
knows when to be funny couple of other
tiny random things before I close out I
love the interaction between the doctor
and Donna you
okay I will be what a million years like
the when in a million years like that's
cute but it's the are you okay I will be
that's beautiful because sometimes
that's the truth are you okay no but I
will be like I'm going to be okay but
but right now no no I'm not and I love
that as an answer I love the Simplicity
of it and I love the sentiment that it
uh that it conveys so the doctor going
like Isaac Newton was hot he was wasn't
he he was so hot
oh that now I have mixed feelings about
that I mean on the one hand it seems to
confirm that at the very least this
incarnation of the doctor is bisexual if
not gay well it was never that far from
the surface mate which okay like this
might be just like the 10th that doesn't
necessarily mean same uh preferences in
terms of romance or sex um but you know
having that all right but I also feel
kind of weird about it especially that
it starts with Donna being like he's
really hot was it me or was Isaac Newton
hot cuz regardless of who he cast as
Isaac Newton Isaac
Newton somewhat famously like seemed to
be sex repulsed like it's it's it's a
little bit of a of an extrapolation on
my part to make the claim that I think
Isaac Newton was asexual I do actually
think he was but even if we don't know
that for certainty we know from letters
and correspondences he made that he
detested the thought of being sexually
involved with women so the idea that
this scene kicks off with Donna comment
basically sexualizing a guy that we know
detested the idea of sexual intimacy
with women like I know he's dead he's
not be offended I get it it's just I
don't know it made the moment weird for
me it might not have if I hadn't done a
video earlier this year talking about
figures from history that you didn't
know were probably some form of Queer As
far as the evidence for that he didn't
like women well he once accused his
friend John Lock of having quote
endeavored to embroil me with women go
back and check out that video Isaac
Newton was not the only one on there but
I brought him up because I'm pretty sure
he was asexual which is part of the
queer community so I guess because that
stuff was in my mind cuz I looked into
it researched it for that video it made
the moment land weird for me probably
nobody else's problem but mine except
pointing it out it might have made it
some other people's problem sorry if
that was a moment you liked that I've
now ruined it for you I don't mean to do
that it just happens sometimes for the
most part though again I cannot
emphasize enough this is really good
this is the kind of stuff that I love
when Doctor Who does when it
goes something weirder when it strips it
down like okay yeah hold up hold up hold
up we don't need massive cast we don't
need an invading Alien Force seemingly
empty ship two people no tools go this
is the creative spirit that gave us
episodes like midnight but also things
like blink and Heaven Scent and episodes
that I dearly love and this doesn't feel
like it's trying to directly be any of
those it's being its own thing but it's
in that vein it's in that form of like
okay let's do something different this
time and I love this especially paired
with the previous episode because it's
like yeah we can still do the fun stuff
you remember we can also do something
else good good please do both that's
what I want I won't
lie Nostalgia can still hit Me overall I
always want the show to be moving
forward in some way shape or form but I
don't mind the occasional hit of
nostalgia as long as you're also going
to me something different which this is
and it's real really good wild blue
yonder what did you think about this one
Whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe they all help me out be
sure to check out Sunny's work reminder
links down in the description for that
as well and thanks again for sponsoring
this video but what I really want you to
remember is that you are
beautiful you are valid you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zuman Lula
goddess Salida tck the thing that goes
don't get the anime Ruth goer the Garian
Oliver B solitary pictures ol Rick
Bogden Melinda Walters Jen Auntie Kate
808 Becky Sparks forab likes the poodle
Robin Powell t love Tracy scrapit angry
Casper Dave Hall Rosal and Bennett have
fun tonight and thank you for your
support I don't know why I decided to do
that this time but I don't know I'm
having
[Music]
fun oh